Senator Kennedy one of the great figures
Senator Senator Foghorn Leghorn over at
the Capitol
who during a senate hearing reads one of
the books that the Liberals are so upset
at having been banned from public
schools you've heard this from the
Liberals those conservatives those
authoritarians they're trying to ban
books from our schools and that's why
the children won't be exposed to the
these important works of literature well
here are the important works of
literature that the libs want to shove
down your kid's throat
all boys aren't blue
and I will quote from it
I put some lube on and got him on his
knees
and I began to
from behind
I
and kissed him Wally
he asked me to turn over while he's
on himself
this was my
and I was struggling to imagine someone
he got on top and slowly inserted
it was the worst pain I think I have
ever felt in my life
eventually I felt a mix of pleasure with
the pain
close quote all boys aren't blue
yeah I sort of wish my producers had
bleeped out more of that that's
unfortunate but
I'm glad that we played it and I'm glad
that Senator Kennedy read this
the the Liberals the best reaction here
was from this liberal Aaron rupar who's
some lib journalist and he tweets that
he goes Senator John Kennedy having a
very normal one during these Senate
hearings and he then he posts him
reading this book
hold on you're you're making fun of John
Kennedy you're saying it's it's
inappropriate you're insinuating that
it's inappropriate for John Kennedy to
read this in the Senate
that you want to read to students to
minors that you are whining about being
banned from schools this book according
to the publisher is suitable for kids 15
years and up
you think a 15 year old should be
reading that you think a 15 year old
should be reading that in school you
think that only 15 year olds are going
to be reading that if you put a book
like that in school first of all it's
probably going to be a sign that even at
lower ages than that did you ever watch
a PG-13 movie before you were 13 I think
so
put it in the library of these schools
there are going to be kids in that
school who are 14 years old 13 years old
by the way it's probably not only going
to be in the high schools it's probably
going to make it down to the middle
schools who knows how much lower it's
going to get right now go to
goodrances.com use promo code Knowles I
just adore
good ranchers our team is constantly
talking about delicious All-American
meat you know what they like even more
when that American meat is free that's
one of the reasons that these guys love
good ranchers they Source the best meat
in America deliver it to your door even
better right now they're offering two
years of free ground beef to anyone who
subscribes that is a 480 dollar value
not only are you going to get the best
cuts of me from a trusted 100 American
Source company you're also going to lock
in your price for two whole years when
you subscribe to any of their boxes that
is two years of free high quality ground
beef and a locked in price no other Mead
company guarantees anything like that
you should get it right now I don't
actually know how the finances work on
this how they can afford to do it it's
just the best and especially with the
ground beef you're getting the best
burgers I've ever had in my entire life
you're getting steak that is absolutely
out of this world every single cut of it
you can get the chicken you get the pork
I just freaking love this company and I
eat it multiple times a week and if
you're not if you're not eating it you
should be when I was kid steak was like
a very rare special treat and the notion
that you could just get great steak now
basically whenever you want is
mind-blowing go to go ranchers.com today
use code Knowles for 25 off and free
ground beef for two years subscribe to
any box to lock in your price on
America's best mate for two whole years
goodrangers.com use code Knowles for
over 500 bucks in savings subscribe to
good ranchers American Meat delivered so
why did Kennedy do this why did I even
play this disgusting clip on this show
it was a trap that Kennedy was setting
Kennedy read that book during the Senate
hearing to get the Aaron rupars of the
world to say what the hell is wrong with
you that's disgusting exactly that is
disgusting
and what he's showing here what Kennedy
is showing here
is that
the the idea that we have in our head of
what a book ban is and the reality of
what a book ban means in practice in
some high school or middle school are
very very different things we living in
our liberal culture
According to which the highest and
actually only moral edict is to just do
whatever you want as an individual we
believe that we should never ban books
there's nothing there's nothing worse
than a book ban in in the modern liberal
mind
and yet you look back through history
Plato supported book Banning and book
burning uh the apostles supported book
Banning and book burning the uh
Christians and westerners going all the
way up through the Middle Ages the
Scholastic supported book bands and book
burning even you get to the Protestant
Revolution Martin Luther I'm not the
biggest Martin Luther guy in the world
but Martin Luther also supported book
Banning book burning you get all the way
up and so you're always wait a second
how come
so many people of prominence many of
whom were very intelligent very serious
people why did they support
certain restrictions on what can be
read in certain places well because
classrooms are like crystal balls
because your mind matters if you if you
just
open your mind and your your mind's eye
up to Filthy disgusting things all the
time like whatever that Virginia House
delegate candidate was doing or whatever
whatever porn these liberals want 12
year olds to be reading in school it's
gonna it's gonna mess up your mind it's
gonna mess up your desires it's going to
mess up your ability to control your
actions with your rational will that's
why they're trying to do it and that's
why serious Statesmen and serious
Educators for all of history have said
no you got to be careful about this and
you can't just have a totally open
society as the Liberals tell us to do
you have to have decent limits
especially
when we're talking about
education and Early Education
because a third grade classroom is not
going to be the place where you debate
uh contentious matters of philosophy
third grade classroom is where you are
taught as a matter of Road coercion
basic stuff to Tamp down your appetite
exercise your rational will and then
hopefully be able to resist this crap
when you become an adult and the lips
keep trying to force it on you boy what
a great clip that was now make sure that
you subscribe to the Michael Knowles
YouTube channel ring that Bell
see you next time